in World War one toxic gas was a weapon
of choice today law enforcement uses a
less potent recipe to pacify a room or
control a crowd but what's inside a can
of tear gas
it starts with charcoal that's wood
burnt until almost nothing is left for
carbon just like in your backyard
barbecue charcoal keeps things smoking
but instead of lighter fluid we add a
dusting of ancient chemistry potassium
nitrate in the 13th century it was known
as Chinese snot a key ingredient of
gunpowder and fireworks kno3 makes
charcoal easy to ignite and as it burns
it releases oxygen fueling the fire at
2,500 degrees tiny grains of silicon
melt into superhot pellets of glass
that's spatter and ignite other
flammables in the mix like potassium
Cora which makes smoke but it's also
dangerously explosive if conditions get
too acidic
that's where magnesium carbonate comes
in
the same stuff you find in fire
extinguishers it neutralizes acid
keeping the whole thing from turning
into a bulb so instead of blowing up all
that sound and fury activates a
chlorobenzene Milano nitrile the lock
Roma tar or tear producer it's a king of
irritants attacking the mucous membranes
of your ears nose and lungs making it
cough choke and go temporarily blind it
would be deadly at concentrations more
than six thousand times greater feeling
wired yet subscribe